[Music]
could you just introduce yourself my
name is Doug Kenney I started the
National Lampoon what if you say I was
the man who changed comedy forever but I
couldn't change myself really blow me if
we're running our own magazine we can do
anything we want if you publish
knock-knock jokes
knock-knock who's that me me hurt me not
doing a magazine
that can go an issue what total failure
we're selling less than half our print
whoa
[Applause]
[Applause]
the Mormons are protesting the feminist
ADA what do we do to the Catholics liza
minnelli we are being sued by Disney
maybe it wasn't such a hot idea to have
Minnie Mouse flashing her test
she has pasties on high ready girls
three two one Catrin I'm the woman
you're heading on Kenny Chagrin Falls
Ohio we're barely able to put out a
magazine telling us barely be able to do
something else the First National
Lampoon musi laser orgy girls
Doug Kenney Chagrin Falls Ohio one of
the writers of Animal House we call this
success mostly an excuse to party ruin
this company failure I do care about you
Doug
laughs god damn it
need to see some money I'm sure it's
gonna be just crazy dog
we need to decide is it clear he's
jerking his dick off here yeah cuz you
can make it higher or lower depending on
the size of my dog these actors don't
look exactly like the real people but
come on
you think I look like Will Forte when I
was 27 you think Will Forte is 27
let's do this this is for the magazine
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]